good evening everyone uh welcome to this
press conference in the framework of the
visit of the College of Commissioners to
the Belgian presidency with Belgian
prime minister Alexander D and European
commission president Ursula
wonderlan um both uh excellencies will
first uh give a statement and we'll then
take some questions uh from you um prime
minister you have the
floor good evening everyone welcome uh
welcome here is the microphone working
yes the microphone is working let me
start again good evening everyone
welcome uh welcome here dear Ursula
welcome here let me start by saying
Europe is coming home and we are
extremely delighted of course to take
over this rotating uh presidency um
there have been quite a few starts of
this European presidency let me say that
this really today has been uh has been
the real start uh we've had the occasion
to discuss with uh with with with our
government and with the college a number
of uh a number of topics and I have to
say that we are extremely excited to uh
to get to work um the relationship
between the presidency of the Council of
the European Union and the um and the
European commission is an extremely
important one in the world of today if
you want to uh realize something you
need to work together and the
cooperation between the Belgian
government and the college really is a
um is a crucial one our presidency comes
at an an important time more than ever
European population looks at the
European Union they look at the European
Union with clear expectations with
expectations to protect them with
expectations to strengthen our
well-being our welfare and with
expectations to prepare a
common future a common future here in
Europe means also of course Ukraine in
the heart of Europe
it is the best guarantee for our future
stability and for a collective security
collective security for the population
of Ukraine but also collective security
for the European
population
um after uh the December decision of the
European Council we will work on the
negotiation framework for future
enlargement related to Ukraine and mova
and this relates to a a broader topic of
course we we live in a in a world that
is in turmoil not only in Ukraine also
in the Middle East and in too many
places in the world we as Europeans too
often we bear the majority of the
consequences of what is happening in the
world what you need to do as European
Union is also to lead in the discussion
not only lead in the discussion with
words but also lead in a discussion with
actions not only bear the consequences
of what happens but also try to
influence what is happening in the um in
in the world we will also prepare the
next institutional cycle uh we will
support the work that is happening in
defining the priorities for the next
five years one of those priorities will
be on how to make the realization of the
green deal something where our full
population our full economy our full
industry can be part of this can see
this as an advantage in and realizing it
not only for the good of Nature and for
the good of our environment for also
something that creates Prosperity that
creates uh that creates welfare that
also means that we need to um reform the
European Union we know that there is
discussions about enlargement at some
point our message is uh very clear
before we get bigger we need to get
better we need the European Union that
is able to decide in a faster way while
maintaining its unity and that is more
efficient in the usage of the resources
that our European population is giving
uh to
them a number of us this morning were in
uh were in Paris and we were there for
the um commemoration of the loss of uh
of jacqu delore if today we Europeans
enjoy the European Union in our daily
lives in our daily lives by using the
Euro by traveling throughout throughout
the European Union without Without
Borders by having programs such as
arasmus Jac delore really was one of the
architects of the modern Europe that we
see today I think more than ever the
spirit of Jac delore is something uh
something we uh something we need a
Europe that understands that we are
stronger together Europe that
understands that it is good to have
friends in the world of uh today so
while doing all of this um we will keep
our citizens at the top priority of all
the work that we do they expect Europe
that protects they expect Europe that
strengthens and they expect a Europe
that prepares so the next six months we
will be uh working together with
European commission with the other
member states with the European
Parliament as well let me conclude by
saying it is crunch time
uh crunch time means that now it is up
to us to
deliver Madame President Merc Merc sh
Alexandre thank you Alexander it's a big
pleasure for me to be here today as we
launched the Belgian presidency of the
Council of ministers and uh firstly to
be able to benefit for some of the
artistic historical Treasures here in
Brussels because even if we live and
work here every day
unfortunately opportunities to benefit
from this Heritage are far too few the
Belgian presidency is therefore welcome
to recall for us the exceptional role
which Belgium has played in European
history and this role continues with
this presidency which is coming at such
an important moment in time your
presidency will be a presidency
when it comes to the landing strip for a
whole range of pieces of work which were
started under my presidency and I'm
counting on the uh talents and the uh
talents of Belgium known in particular
because of the Excellence of your
cyclist to actually get us through the
final furong now we have got some very
important files that we need to close
all of them or everyone has to
contribute to the aims of your
protect uh reinforce prepare the
priorities which you have are ones which
I share fully priorities that is the
support for
Ukraine we all witnessed Russia's recent
brutal air strikes on civilian Targets
in
Ukraine and after the historic decision
to launch accession negotiations with
Ukraine we must urgently move forward on
stabilizing our financial aid to to the
country the commission will come to the
European Council with operational
solutions to ensure that we can agree on
the Ukraine
facility and Belgium will then have the
key task of transforming the political
agreement on the facility through
Council and Parliament as quickly as
possible the Ukraine facility is a
central element of the revision of the
multiannual budget but but it is not the
only one we need to conclude the
revision during the Belgian presidency
and this will give us the means to
implement many of the policy priorities
that we have identified and on which we
have made progress take for example
migration with a recent political
agreement on The Pact we have now the
basis for a new and effective policy and
it will be important to bring these
files now over the Finish Line another
example is
competitiveness I very much look forward
to an agreement between Parliament and
Council on our proposal for the Net Zero
industry act because this will provide
our industry with a greatly improved
regulatory framework to drive forward
the green and digital
transition of course competitiveness is
a wide theme with many different
angles so we also need modernized fiscal
rules that help stimulate sustainable
investment throughout
Europe and the agreement in Council a
few weeks ago was a very welcome step
forward now I am confident that the
Belgian presidency can ensure an
agreement with the parliament before the
end of this
mandate we ALS also need very strong
social dialogue first because long-term
competitiveness we li first and foremost
on Europe's main talent and that's the
people and their
skills and second because
competitiveness is a tool to ensure
prosperity and this is prosperity for
all so I'm very much looking forward to
the values Summit to discuss the future
of work and I share your OB objective to
sign an interinstitutional Declaration
on social Europe in laul with a focus on
a new drive for implementing the
European pillar of social
rights and I'm also very much looking
forward to our discussions on the two
reports you mentioned the r report by
enria on the single market and the
report by Mario Mario dragi on
competitiveness more generally I am
convinced that these reports will
provide inspiration for new initiatives
to reinforce our long-term
competitiveness dear Alexander one of
your presidency's priorities is to
prepare for the future and my college
entering its last year of mandate will
continue to work hard to do just that
let me mention two points we will come
for forward in particular with a
communication on the 2040 climate
targets and after the cop 28 and the
success on our European Initiative for
Global Targets on Renewables and Energy
Efficiency
worldwide it is important for the
European Union to continue to set the
standards and the
trends and
second following the decision of the
last European Council as you said we
must prepare for an enlarged Union and
before we get bigger we have to get
better so during the Belgian presidency
we will come forward with our road map
for policy reviews and I look forward to
discussing them with
you the European Union we both are
striving for is a union that delivers
and a union that empowers so let's go to
work thank you thank you thank you very
much excellencies um we will take some
questions now please uh state your name
and the media you work for before asking
your question uh
paa with the financial times um a
question to prime minister the crew
perhaps you were in Paris you mentioned
where prime minister Victor Orban was
also in attendance do you have a feeling
that a solution at 27 for financing
Ukraine is possible and Madame President
may I ask you said you will have
operational Solutions ready what is the
earliest day that you can get Aid to
Ukraine thank you so
much yeah thank you uh great question
yes of course the uh the aim is to is to
come to an agreement with with 27
countries and we've had over the past
two years other moments where there was
doubt and I often call it the the
Brussels doubt it is a few hours before
a European Council everyone starts
doubting if it is possible and up to now
every time we've come with with a
solution so I see no reason that uh
besides the Brussels doubts we will also
have the Brussels decisiveness and and
come to an agreement with uh with the 27
countries yes and indeed um this is the
first priority an agreement to 20 by 27
but of course we have to prepare for
other options these are the operational
solutions that we are preparing right
now important is uh to know that we have
just released Before Christmas the last
Tran of our 18 billion Euro support
package for Ukraine for
2023 so this will help Ukraine Finance
their needs for the beginning of this
year this gives us a little bit of
leeway but of course we have to work as
hard and as fast as possible to
deliver yes
please
Bloomberg thank you very much I have two
questions to Madame President and also
to prime minister um one of the focuses
during the presidency uh will be
relationship with China I imagine and we
have a recent development of starting
the uh anti-dumping investigation
against uh EU leaker uh do you see this
as retaliation and do you think that
this uh kind of tit forat can um spill
over into a bigger trade fight and a
second question uh prime minister you
have uh spoken a few times about the
importance of not just having the green
deal uh but also having the industrial
deal uh what are the particulars what do
you want to see in in that industrial
act thank
you so um what our relationship uh to
China is concerned it is very important
to be very Frank about the facts we have
a 400 billion trade deficit with China
and um it increased drastically over the
last years so uh when I visited China I
was very clear on that that yes we like
competition that is good but it has
to be fair there has to be a Level
Playing Field and it has to be
transparent so when it comes to
subsidies for example we have to have
transparency about what kind of
subsidies are given and under what
circumstances and this is the discussion
we are leading with China my experience
is that the more open the more Frank you
are uh the more you can really uh
pinpoint on uh the the difficult points
in the economic relationship we have
agreed with the Chinese leadership that
we will go Point by Point through all
the complaints we have and our companies
in China for example experience and have
and work through them systematically so
that we do not only have um the uh
complaint on The Superficial level but
um step by step we go through all the
difficulties um for example European
companies face when they want to access
the Chinese
market maybe on on uh on on on on the
green deal and Industry and I think uh
too often there are people who try to
oppose one against the one against the
other and I think that's wrong and I
think it's remarkable what we have done
I mean European continent has been going
through major crisis over the past three
years and I'm extremely proud that the
commission was able to maintain the
goals of the green deal we were all very
clear on keeping the goal now that we
get into a next phase where we hope we
can let the crisis behind it we have to
come into a new phase of policy which
means how do we make the green deal
bankable how do we make it something
where our industry where our population
sees it as a source not only for
Advantage from an environmental point of
view but also competitive Advantage also
a source as a better life a cheaper life
a more affordable life for our uh for
our population now how to do this a few
things have already been mentioned and
roleta is is doing great work on the
version 2.0 of the single Market we
talked about Jac delore what was done
more than 30 years ago was Visionary but
the world has changed quite a bit since
then our economy is completely different
than anything we could have imagined 30
years ago the work ofri coleta the work
of Mario dragi is a key input in uh in
that you talked about about China and
about trade it is clear that trade
policy is a part of industrial policy
and we need to better integrate our
trade policy in our industrial goals the
European continent is today the
continent of
innovation but industrializing that
Innovation too often is happening in
some other places we are a continent
with a lot of financing which is
available but today a big part of our
Pension funds are being invested in the
United States whereas they could rather
be invested invested in the
industrialization of the Innovation that
is happening uh is happening here so
that industrial deal is something that
is quite broad but that we finally need
to put in a package and help it to
become a second phase of really um
firing up the uh the green
deal okay have time for last question
political hi um Peter H from political I
had a question on the escalation we've
seen in the Red Sea the last few weeks
um we've seen some member states already
speaking out that there would maybe be
consequences maybe Mr Prime Minister do
you going to use the presidency to uh
push for a more common EU approach to
protect the global trade flows
there um if in my introduction I talked
about the fact that too often when there
are worldwide events we Europeans we
bear the brunt of the of the
consequences too often when there are
Refugee flows because of a conflict we
are the one that uh that take the major
part of it when we see that energy
prices go up because of international
tensions we are the one who are uh who
are paying it so um instead of being a
payer too often we've said we need to be
we need to be a player that means that
in these situations we need to do a much
more proactive effort in trying to get
everyone on the same line now that is an
easy thing to say we know that um um uh
conflicts like that are often not the
easiest one to get uh to get everyone uh
aligned but yes it is definitely uh one
of our Ambitions is uh to try to work in
the most proactive way as possible to
get uh to get to a common position and
to also get to
action
okay will contribute to Red Mission if
one takes place oh if questions are
always hard to
answer okay I think your time is up uh
unfortunately but thank you very much
and hope to see you very soon thank you
all right thank you thank
you thank you thank you
yes I'm going
to